we're going to get an exclusive inside
look at what happened behind the scenes
in the high profile defamation trial
between johnny depp and his ex-wife
that's amber heard now the court ordered
her to pay debt more than 10.3 million
and debt to pay her 2 million for her
counter claim but ultimately it was depp
who appeared to win in the court of
opinion big time many credit depths
attorneys that would be ben chu and
camille vasquez now vasquez says it
would not have been possible without the
team of young associates we spoke with
her about how they work together and
their strategy
have a seat the sordid defamation trial
between johnny depp and amber hurd was
watched by millions
respectfully
that's not my question but it was depp's
attorney camille vasquez who appeared to
be the breakout star this certainly has
catapulted you to a whole different
level there are now t-shirts that's that
have your face on it camille vasquez
there are mugs people are coming to you
with
book deals i would imagine tv deals
offers to open your own law firm which
that would be my vote or to join their
firm
how are you handling this newfound fame
doing my best it's overwhelming i was
wondering it's surreal i i was speaking
to some friends
last week and i said i've had so many
pinch me moments and tell us what it
took to defend johnny depp because you
you seem to be a small but young mighty
team
we were strong and young right i mean
it's a story that i don't think has been
told until now we were most of us under
40 years old which is unique for a case
of this magnitude
this case i think called for a younger
team
why why did you think that because the
parties were young right and they
resonate with a younger audience and
you need their perspectives i think
young people have a fresh perspective on
especially these issues the issues that
we were discussing in this case
abuse me too
those were the issues so camille vasquez
who just turned 38 and ben chu a partner
at their law firm brown rudnick brought
in five associates including 32 year old
sam moniz that jury was taking its
responsibilities seriously and 34 year
old jessica myers to help fill out
depp's legal roster
we met them at their new york city
office
how did you pick these two to be on your
team
well jessica's a fantastic writer as is
sam and i think for people that know a
little bit about the law it's not just
what's on camera right it's not just us
objecting and getting to do the fun
things right like a witness and so for
ben and me i mean we just identified
talent
so the lack of experience and age didn't
seem daunting or wasn't concerning to
any of you
to any of you you know in my experience
i think young attorneys they're closer
to sort of the laws and the rules
because we're the ones who are sort of
researching that and so i think it was
actually an asset overall sam and closer
to the facts too you know you get in the
weeds and the facts and i think this is
a great team i mean
lack of experience aside and we do have
some experience yeah lack of experience
i like that sam you know we have some
experience
i'm not trying to say you didn't know
what you're doing but you know what i
mean when you look at the big picture
and this was such a big case but there
was a lot of raw talent on this team too
i mean camille became a star for good
reason just did you know just did
johnny's direct examination and did a
phenomenal job and you know there was a
reason she was put up there to do it it
was because the partners and everybody
knew she could let's talk about that you
did johnny you did the direct
examination of johnny depp your honor we
call mr john c depp i had done a witness
at a trial before but this was the first
time i had done a direct examination
right
so take us inside your head that morning
you know there was a level of nerves i
think i kept waiting for this
overwhelming sense of nerves but i think
you know once you get up there it just
feels kind of natural and you just
you you know do what you do sam for you
was there a turning point for you in the
case actually i think for me it was more
of a gradual process of realizing that
our story was coming in things can go
very badly wrong at any moment and they
never went wrong and we told the story
we set out to tell let's talk about
cameras in the courtroom camille because
amber heard's team did not want cameras
in the courtroom why did you want
cameras in the courtroom i think it was
important to the client for johnny it
was about finally being able to tell his
story
and
these these are
horrific allegations that were made
against him he needed to be able to tell
his story so you know what then you know
what camille there were horrific
allegations on both sides i mean i think
some people could look and say were
there any winners here clearly he won in
the court of public opinion clearly he
won legally too but was he damaged in
any way because of this
i think he came into this case thinking
he had nothing else left to lose gail
and i think for him it was
he had to put it all out there vasquez
says the team of younger attorneys gave
them another advantage
something i didn't say which i'll say to
you now is that
i think
the pressure of it all made us probably
over prepare
so we were really prepared and i think
that can't be
understated you know there were also
with all of the fame also comes all the
um
pettiness some cattiness and some could
say haterade i call it because there are
a lot of social media rumors that you
and johnny depp were romantically
involved right
why do you think those rumors started
and what did you think when you heard
them it was disappointing to hear them
but i think they started because people
like
love stories they like
to make things up right um doesn't mean
they're true and obviously in this case
they weren't true never have been true
i think people thought well you know
they are kind of touchy feely
sure but i'm touchy feely with everyone
i mean that's just who i am i'm
naturally described as a warm person i
and i and i don't think there's anything
wrong with caring for your clients right
i was fighting for his life his name
it's perfectly normal i think to be able
to extend a hand and give him a hug and
make him feel like he was protected we
all were that way with him each other
and with him just supportive and
protective do you have a long-term goal
as you sit here today
i don't have a long-term goal except i
want to continue my practice i'm a
lawyer when i look at myself in the
mirror i see an advocate i was born to
do this i really feel that way
i do when is vasquez and associates
going to open i'll let you know
you're the first to know gail
i'm going to hold her to that as we said
earlier we have reached out to amber
hurd and her attorneys and are not
commenting at this time as you might
expect camille vasquez's phone is
ringing off the hook from men who are
reaching out who have behaved badly or
accused of behaving badly with women and
in business
she said their names that we all know
she would not share them i tried
she would not say who that is but she
said i don't want to be known as that
guy you know that if you're in trouble
you know camille can uh can help you in
the case she said listen i had worked
for johnny depp for four years they had
done cases together she knew him very
well she believed him but you know a lot
of people believed amber her too and i
don't want that to get lost in that
story right because she was so vilified
and so attacked on social media and you
know as we sit here today she's still
you know
being vilified and attacked and i i
think something the whole thing was very
messy there was mississippi but at the
end the jury decided and they decided in
favor of johnny depp so you know camille
is on to her next case and now everybody
knows her name
she's somebody that just really loves
the job that she does you know she said
my my goal is that once once i do a case
with you i hope that you'll never need
my services again
that is the whole time
and the young people behind the scenes
the young people behind this that was
the story she wanted to tell right she
said you know because i'm getting all
the attention
but people worked really hard on this
case for a very long time and that the
firm recognized that having younger
attorneys because these two uh the two
people that were contesting this were
fairly known to younger people that it
probably helped in that strategy yeah
and immediately after that verdict came
in uh camille was promoted to partner
immediately
i think a lot of people saw that coming
yes